[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
enlightenment which professes to be pure
here converts what is for spirit eternal
life and Holy Spirit into an actual
perishable thing and defiles it with
sense certainties view of it a viewpoint
which is essentially trivial and
definitely absent from faith in its
worship so that enlightenment is
completely in the wrong when it imputed
this view to faith what faith Revere's
it certainly does not regard as stone or
wood or donor or any other kind of
temporal sensuous thing if enlightenment
has a mind to say that all the same its
object is also this or even that it is
essentially and in truth this then
firstly faith is equally well aware of
that also which however lies outside of
its worship secondly however faith does
not regard such things as stones etc as
possessing intrinsic being on the
contrary what has intrinsic being for
faith is solely the essential being of
pure thought
paragraph 553 continues along more or
less the same lines as the paragraphs
just preceding it setting out what
Hegel's critique or you know negative
attitude you could say towards the
negative attitude or critique taken by
the Enlightenment against faith
representing faith as a sort of naivete
so he tells us that enlightenment which
professes to be pure carries out a kind
of conversion a conversion that is
actually you could say insofar as it's
related to its other a kind of
perversion misrepresenting I almost said
willfully misrepresenting but I think
that Hegel portrays this is not being
entirely willful in the sense of
deliberate it is willful in the sense of
not really understanding what it's
supposed to be doing not actually
grasping the things in front of it so
there is a kind of Wilk er arbitrariness
to it right so Hegel says that
enlightenment converts what is for
spirit what is for something greater
than just the Enlightenment form of
consciousness what is for consciousness
is such eternal life and Holy Spirit
into an actual perishable thing now why
does it do that
because faith is relating itself to
eternal life to the Holy Spirit to
whatever it is we're you know the
unchanging through the sensuous thing
through some sort of contingent time
bound space bound this rather than that
for example you know in terms of think
about the Eucharist right and the
insistence that it be bread made from
wheat and not from corn or some other
grain why I that insistence on this sort
of thing you know
faith has its reasons for doing so but
these reasons are being discounted by
the Enlightenment so he says it defiles
you
what is it defiling the the sensuous
thing and eternal life in the Holy
Spirit with sense certainties view of it
now what was sense certainties view of
the sensuous thing at the beginning it
was treating it as a complete positivity
just is what it is right and then the
question was how does it identify what
it is you know in terms of its essence
or meaning what it has to reveal to us
and then of course we went through this
entire dialectic you know the thing in
its properties and force in the
understanding which took us quite away
from sense certainty but now we're back
here with sense certainty being imposed
on the thing from the perspective of the
Enlightenment why because the
Enlightenment says the person of faith
or the institution or organization of
faith is actually just engaging in this
this sense certainty and it's portraying
this thing as an absolute so he says
this is a viewpoint which is essentially
trivial and definitely absent from faith
in its worship so Hegel says here
enlightenment is completely in the wrong
when it impedes this view to faith
enlightenment may look at the sensuous
thing may look at the temple may look at
the sacrifice may look at the and
whatever other physical apparatus or
props or whatever you want to call it or
even the things that are being centered
upon say a statue and say listen all
that's there is a sensuous thing
time-bound contingent thing you people
of faith that's all that you're grasping
and and Hegel says this is almost
deliberately obtuse because all you have
to do is observe the people motivated by
faith not not just by you know say using
religion or or you know superstition but
people who are genuinely motivated by
faith and see that for them the the
sensuous thing is a symbol it is
something that offers
a way for the absolute eternal life Holy
Spirit to be grasped by the individual
through something else so he says what
faith Revere's this is you could say
this is what's being left out in a sense
the Enlightenment or pure insight
doesn't grasp what it is not just what
it is that faith Revere's but what it is
to revere or you could say that it does
understand it but it understands it in
such a way as to deprive faith of the
very comportment that the Enlightenment
might say about freedom or human dignity
or you know whatever you you would like
to say human maybe the the ultimate
creator for talking about deism right so
he says what faith Revere's it certainly
does not regard as stone or wood or
dough or any other kind of temporal
sensuous thing so Hegel says
enlightenment now is in kind of a bind
either it can recognize that or and this
is where Hegel actually follows out the
path of consciousness because
enlightenment in many of its cases
doesn't say that enlightenment doesn't
look at the person of faith as it will
later on doing say philosophy of
religion or something like that or you
know sociology or some other way in
which we try to get inside the head in
the hearts of the people of faith
instead he says if enlightenment has a
mind to say that all the same it's
object is also this even though it's a
symbol for this look what you're really
doing is focusing on this sensuous thing
whatever it happens to be then he says
or even that it is essentially - in
truth this then faith so here we see a
dialectic in process right faith is not
just this purely passive comportment in
relation to enlightenment the people of
faith know that the enlightened ones or
the people of pure insight are
criticizing them are saying listen
you're a bunch of dummies you don't even
know what you're doing you're not
understanding what it is that
you're relating yourself to your you
know going after this centrist thing the
people of faith can say we realize that
you think that's what we're doing but
that's not exactly what our
consciousness is all about so why are
you miss representing us so Hegel says
that faith is equally aware of that also
which however lies outside of its
worship it's not so important what the
vestments look like it's not so
important whether the bread is leavened
or unleavened all right
even those who made arguments for
lavender unleavened bread at least
acknowledge that it really any bread
would do just one is more appropriate
and one is less appropriate right and we
could go on and on and on you know does
it have to be wine or if you can't get
any grape wine could it be something
else well you know that's up for
discussion and same thing with any other
religious system when it becomes
insistence upon no only this class a
sensuous thing there is a danger for
faith that faith is quite aware of of
the connection to eternal life with the
Holy Spirit being lost the the absolute
what it is that it's actually seeking in
its worship so he says it's a well aware
that this also lies outside of its
worship secondly faith does not regard
things like stones pieces of wood bread
as possessing intrinsic being on the
contrary what has intrinsic being what
what is the thing that's valuable for
faith is solely the essential being of
pure thought which is this this absolute
but also the compartment of the
individual in relation to the absolute
like I said the sensuous thing is merely
a symbol or you might say instrument by
which the person of faith can relate
themselves to the eternal life we might
say similarly about rituals gestures we
might say similar about linguistic
formulations you know is this particular
liturgy
of absolute importance so that if you if
you mumble the words or you mix the
words up it's no good and it doesn't
really you throw the absolute the person
of faith you know the person of genuine
faith not superstition would say no of
course not it's it's the meaning of what
you're trying to accomplish that is
really important but enlightenment
mistakes that and misrepresents faith
the second moment is the relation of
faith to this absolute being in a
consciousness that knows it for faith as
a thinking pure consciousness this being
is immediately present but pure
consciousness is just as much a mediated
relation of certainty to truth a
relation which constitutes the ground of
faith for enlightenment this ground
becomes equally a fortuitous knowledge
of fortuitous events but the ground of
knowledge is the conscious universal and
in its truth is absolute spirit which an
abstract pure consciousness or in
thought as such is merely absolute being
but Kwas self-consciousness is knowledge
of itself pure insight characterizes
this conscious universal the simple self
knowing spirit equally as a negative of
self consciousness it is true that pure
insight is itself pure mediated that is
self mediated thought is a pure knowing
but since it is a pure insight appear
knowing that does not as yet know itself
that is not aware that it is this pure
mediating movement the mediation seems
to insight as does everything that is
itself insight to be another in its
realization therefore it develops this
moment which is essential to it but this
moment seems to it to belong to faith
and they have the character of something
external to pure insight to be a
fortuitous knowledge of narratives of
real events real in the ordinary sense
of the word here therefore it it falsely
charges religious belief with basing at
certainty on some particular historical
evidences which considered as historical
evidences would certainly not guarantee
the degree of certainty about their
content which is given by newspaper
accounts of any happening further that
and it's that its certainty rests on the
accidental preservation of these
evidences on the one hand the
preservation by means of paper and on
the other by the skill and honesty of
their transference from one piece of
paper to another and lastly on the
correct interpretation of the meaning of
dead words and letters in fact however
it does not occur to faith to fasten at
certainty to such evidences and such
fortuitous circumstances faith in its
certainty is an unsophisticated
relationship to its absolute object a
pure knowing of it
which does not mix up letters
paper and copyists in its consciousness
of absolute being and does not bring
itself into relation with it by means of
beings of that kind on the contrary this
consciousness is the self mediating
ground of its knowledge it is spirit
itself which bears witness to itself
both in the inwardness of the individual
consciousness and through the universal
presence in every one of faith in it if
faith wants to appeal to historical
evidences in order to get that kind of
foundation or at least confirmation of
its content that enlightenment talks
about and seriously thinks and acts as
if that were a matter of importance then
it has already let itself be corrupted
by the Enlightenment and its efforts to
establish and consolidate itself in such
a way are merely evidence it gives of
its corruption by the Enlightenment
paragraph 544 is a really remarkable
section because in it we see Hegel at
really the beginning of the 19th century
prefiguring in his own critique the
higher criticism that is going to be
developed over the course of the 19th
century in part taking some of its
origin from his own thought and
proceeding to in essence just the devil
faith and he even sees the problem that
arises when faith attempts to argue with
enlightenment on the very same ground
when faith tries to combat the higher
criticism by you know fighting with the
same tools the same scientific
methodologies that the higher criticism
would would turn against it so what
we're talking about here by higher
criticism is various forms of biblical
scholarship and interpretation but not
just biblical you know one of the things
that I think often gets left out when
we're looking at the history of of you
know recent history the last two
centuries of you know religion versus
science or the humanities or criticism
or things like that is the fact that
it's not just about the Bible the the
same techniques of higher criticism can
be applied to legends and accounts of
the saints for example or they can be
applied outside of christianity and
judaism by extension to other religious
traditions as well so we can talk about
you know not only a quest for the
historical jesus but also a quest for
the historical buddha and and and so on
so all that said let's let's look at
what Hagel himself is saying here now he
begins by date by you know reminding us
that we're looking at the second moment
now we looked at at the absolute being
in
now we're looking at how faith relates
itself in in knowledge how does it how
does faith know absolute being this is a
relation between faith or the
consciousness of faith which is
individuals ended within the community
and absolute being so it says there's a
two-sided 'no stu this faith is a
thinking pure consciousness for that
because it's pure consciousness this
being is immediately present there's no
intermediary and it's just there for it
so you could say well what about all
this other stuff in between then so he
says pure consciousness is a mediated
relation of certainty to truth and we
see Hegel here bringing in his old
familiar categories that he likes to use
certainty and truth there is a sort of
immediate certainty of absolute being on
the part of faith but there's also a
mediation going on and we're gonna have
to look at well what is that mediating
term or rather the plurality of that
mediating term which is what is
providing us here with something going
beyond mere certainty in providing us
with truth or providing rather the
consciousness of faith so he says for
enlightenment or for pure insight this
isn't really truth this is what he calls
what Miller's translating here as a
fortuitous knowledge of fortuitous
events I like the word contingent a
little bit better here savelii ago right
things just happen to be the way they
are you know so you could say well you
know what would be examples of this well
you know in Buddhism the the Buddha
preached at this place after
encountering these representatives of
traditional Hindu and innovative Hindu
practices and then he gave a you know
Four Noble Truths not five not ten
and and if you use this language here we
could say similarly you know that Jesus
did these things healed these people
walked in these places you know uttered
this parable explained this one didn't
explain that one and then we can go on a
little bit further and we can say
there's even you could say contingency
of contingency you know how did these
stories get transmitted somebody had to
say well I think this event is relevant
and this event is less relevant let's
let's write this part down but you know
what he had for lunch on you know this
this day or something like that we're
not gonna worry about that or what color
was the shirt that he was wearing that
day did he change his shirt you know
that's equally contingent but there's
some things that are felt to be more
important than others already you start
to see here the hint of what Hagel is
going to be getting in I think so from
the perspective of the Enlightenment or
insight this negative critique this is
just contingent stuff right and so it's
a contingent knowledge we just happen to
have this knowledge of contingent events
or you know the German for this is but
Gabe and height and the things that are
just given to us the things that we
happen to find in our our paths the
things that happen to be preserved you
could say or let me literally give him
so he says the ground of knowledge is
however the conscious universal so
enlightenment and insight wants to
retain that entirely to itself and were
the conscious universal you are not a
conscious universal you're a conscious
individual and you're relating yourself
to the unconscious universal over here
through all this crazy stuff these
stories that you're telling these relics
these whatever they happen to be walking
a you know the same path think about
people like you know choosing to go to
Israel because they want to walk in the
Holy Land and see the same Jordan -
right and see the same sort of things
that the you know the apostles were
supposed to be seeing or than where
Jesus walked or however you want to put
it you know from the perspective of
enlightenment and insight that's just
nonsense why would you bother doing that
sort of stuff you know that reminds me
actually of something that Maurice
Blondell said about how people were
treating Christianity at the time that
he defended his dissertation lacs you
know he said that one of his classmates
had said to him you know why should what
happened in some obscure corner of the
Roman Empire and was unnoticed by nearly
anybody who mattered at the time
mattered to us now in the 19th century
he's saying this near the end of the
19th century in France rather than
Germany but it's the same sort of
sentiment so he goes on and he says the
ground of the knowledge is the conscious
universal in its truth is absolute
spirit which in abstract pure
consciousness or in thought as such it's
merely absolute being but as
self-consciousness is knowledge of
itself so this is a very important point
faith is starting to approach not just
knowledge of the absolute being but some
sort of recuperation that relates it to
the absolute being as involving some
knowledge not just of another out there
but of itself the pure insight is taking
a stand saying faith you're not doing
that I'm doing that we're doing that we
enlightened ones so he goes on and he
says it's true
that pure insight is itself pure
mediated that is self mediated thought
it is a pure knowing but and we've seen
this come up over and over and over
again since it is a pure insight a pure
knowing that does not as yet know itself
right it's it's critical in that it
turns against faith and all this other
stuff but it's not sufficiently
self-critical
even though faith is teaching it some
lessons along the way that it could be
learning Hegel would would say that you
what he's doing is actually you might
say pure insight squared or
enlightenment squared again I've talked
about this before in an article called
the second enlightenment so he says it's
not aware that it is this pure mediating
movement the mediation seems to incite
to be another and other that cannot be
assimilated another that does not make
sense for it and other that stands
opposed to it so he says in its
realization it develops this moment
which is essential to it but this moment
seems to belong who - who - faith so
really you know what's going on here is
more the initiative on the side of faith
rather than pure inside so he says it
seems to have the character of something
external to pure insight pure insight or
critical you know you might say a
critical negative point of view is not
yet critical enough because it is again
not self critical and not self critical
not just in sort of a navel-gazing way
but self critical of itself in relation
to its other it's fascinating to see
this because you will see I brought up
maurice blundell maurice blown Della's
called the catholic Hegel much of what
he's carrying out in his work in his
discussion of the relationship between
philosophy and religion is treading this
same path that Hegel himself is charting
out here in this section on faith and
enlightenment so he goes on and he tells
us this is very important right here
here we go it develops this this moment
which seems to be essential to it but
the moment belongs to faith and hands
the character something external to peer
insight what a fortuitous knowledge of
narratives of real events real in the
ordinary sense of the word what does
Hegel mean thereby real in the ordinary
sense of the word real as in being
presented as actual not real is in they
really are actual or we
can attest to this or we have historical
evidences for this but real you might
say in a rather pragmatic way
so here again Hegel tells us
enlightenment is getting things wrong he
says it falsely charges religious belief
with something what is he charging a
religious belief with basing its
certainty why why is it you know it
would be right to say it bases its truth
but it's not it's certainty that it's
basing on this basing its certainty on
some particular historical evidences
which considered as historical evidences
was certainly not guaranteed the degree
of certainty about their content which
is given by newspaper accounts of any
happening so this is very important
right what Hegel is saying here is that
the Enlightenment treats the narratives
let's call them sacred narratives or
narratives of the holy narratives that
are infused and imbued with some sort of
religious meaning as if they are the
same kind of narratives as anything else
so the Gospels become merely a
historical document that when we look at
in terms of a historical document we
said well it's not very good right even
if by the standards of ancient
historiography which you know if we
actually study this sort of thing we
would realize those standards are not
extraordinarily high you know they get
through Sidda teased or Josephus or
people like that right so what do what
else can we say about this they're being
treated as merely historical and Hegel
uses this comparison to newspaper events
what gives us the reason to think that
anything in the newspaper or if we might
think about our own time on a website is
actually true now you know we have some
interesting new standards we like
photographic and video evidence or
recordings but we're now at the point
where a good bit of that can be an often
indeed is faked and we can say similar
things about written things and
and we live in an environment where of
course you and I cannot go and handle
firsthand all of the historical
documents we have to rely on facts
similes much of the time so he points
something out here and this is very
important in the critique that the
Enlightenment makes of of faith in the
19th century he says that this certainty
rests on the accidental preservation of
these evidences on the one hand the
preservation by means of paper so we
have written things right on the other
by the skill and honesty of their
transference from one paper to another
lastly on the correct interpretation of
the meaning of dead words and letters so
in this entire part right here this
mediating term where we have knowledge
of contingent knowledge of contingent
events Hegel's pointing out that what we
what we're relying on is some sort of
written testimony written testimony that
we can't be entirely sure we should
trust written testimony that has had to
come down to us through copying copying
copying copying where there may be
interpolations there may be mistakes
that get made in transmission there may
be deliberate editorial you know
censuring of parts there may be in fact
fabrications that are taking place let's
just use a different example let's think
about Epictetus --is and karidian
so we have a work of stoic philosophy
and if the only copies that we had were
the ones that came to us through certain
monasteries we would think that
Epictetus was a Christian because they
had changed some of the words you know
for example philosopher gets changed to
anchorite which is a certain kind of
monk right and we could go on and on and
on so how do we know here's the the
fundamental challenge how do we know
that any of these religious texts that
we are placing so much reliance in are
really accurate that they do in fact
represent
what the original authors wrote since we
don't have any of the original texts and
how do we know that those people didn't
make some of it up or didn't write the
wrong things down or weren't confused
about what they were encountering or
perhaps where didn't have the language
to adequately express it these are
fundamental challenges that get raised
so and these are the sort of things that
you know you know we're being brought up
by people like for example David Hume
you know just read his natural history
of religion published after his death of
course and you get a great example of
this sort of idea and there are many
other people who are pointing out
similar issues again representing the
alignment with religious documents
primarily in the West that has to do
with Christianity but you could apply
this across the board so Hegel goes on
and he says on the contrary on the
contrary
this consciousness what consciousness
the consciousness of faith this
consciousness is the self median
mediating ground of its knowledge it you
could say jumps underneath or over all
of these contingent events those are
great but that's not what's being relied
upon he says its spirit itself which
bears witness to itself how do you know
that there really is a God on the other
side how do you know that that God is
love or that God would reveal him or
herself or itself or whatever in certain
ways not just through the historical
documents but through a relation of
living faith one that might actually
require action right now we're only
talking about knowledge but it could
require action in order to know love
well let's let's consider for example
two Beatitudes right the Beatitudes are
something that comes up with in the
Gospels which are some some documents
right coming from the ancient period but
but written and written and written and
written and we have many copies of them
but how does this itself play out the
attitudes tell us things like blessed
are the peacemakers you know blessed are
those who show mercy blessed are you
know the poor in spirit what why are
they blessed and what what does that
mean then there's these promises for
they shall write and it like in the case
of blessed are those who show mercy it's
a reciprocal mercy shall be shown them
blessed are those who hunger and thirst
for justice they will be satisfied so
maybe you act in such a way right as to
confirm that for yourself and unless you
do that and get away from just the text
itself maybe you don't actually have
that relationship to absolute being he
goes on and he says that it's spirit
that bears witness to itself both in the
inwardness of the individual
consciousness and through the universal
presence in every one of faith in it the
religious community so he says now
there's a danger for faith if faith
starts to play the game of enlightenment
and tries to meet it on the very ground
that it was being critiqued on if faith
he says wants to appeal the historical
evidences to get that kind of foundation
what kind of foundation the kind of
foundation that a lived subjective
experience provides then or at least
confirmation and seriously thinks and
acts as if that were a matter of
importance then it's let itself become
corrupted by enlightenment isn't that an
interesting thing to say what this would
mean is that you know the people who we
call fundamentalists rightly so because
they actually called themselves that
which are a small group of those who we
could much larger group that we can call
biblical literalists right those who
think that the the text itself must be
taken literally that there is you know
the text provides us with with pretty
much everything we need perspicuity of
Scripture we can go on and on and on
with that and I don't want to get too
bogged down in that they made a mistake
they played into the hands of
enlightenment precisely by insisting on
these things being historically accurate
and they thereby
whose what it is that faith is actually
about this is a fundamental thing that
that Hegel is pointing out one that will
be assumed central importance in the
religious life of the 20th century and I
would say continues in the 21st century
so he says it's it's let itself be
corrupted by enlightenment its efforts
to establish and consolidate itself in
such a way become merely evidence it
gives of its own corruption by the
Enlightenment the irony here is who is
it that fundamentalist and other
literalists say is at fault the
Enlightenment
you